لذلك نحن في علامة 300 مليون
جرعة ، ومن الواضح أن
هذا رقم ملحوظ للغاية
هنا من حيث المناعة الشاملة
في الدولة ، فهي ليست 70 بالمائة على
الصعيد الوطني التي أردناها ولكن إذا
نظرت
إلى مقدار المناعة من اللقاحات
و  أضف أيضًا
مقدار المناعة التي تأتي من
الأشخاص الذين أصيبوا بالعدوى بشكل طبيعي ،
فمن المحتمل أن نكون في مناعة قطيع وظيفية
أو قريبًا سنكون هناك لذلك
نرى الأرقام تنخفض
ديون الاستشفاء.
من
المثير للاهتمام أن ننظر حول العالم
إلى هذه المتغيرات ومعرفة مقدار
التأثير الذي تحدثه
إذا ألقيت نظرة على المملكة المتحدة على سبيل المثال ،
أعتقد أن هناك قصة هنا
من المهم أن تراها في
الرسم في نهاية شهر كانون الثاني (يناير)
كان الإصدار ألفا أو المملكة المتحدة
هو السائد في المملكة المتحدة بشكل أساسي ، ومن
المفهوم أن
ما حدث خلال تلك الفترة الزمنية ،
انخفضت الأرقام
بشكل عام وهو أمر جيد ولكن في نفس الوقت
في الوقت الذي بدأ فيه متغير دلتا في
الدخول إلى المشهد هناك ،
رأيت الأرقام المنبثقة التي كانت تظهر في
المقام الأول من الواضح أن الأشخاص الذين لم
يتم تطعيمهم ،
وهذا هو مصدر القلق هنا ونعلم
أن هذا البديل أكثر قابلية للانتقال
في المملكة المتحدة أو البديل ألفا كان  أكثر قابلية للانتقال بنسبة 50 في المائة
من السلالة السابقة ، وهذا
أكثر قابلية للانتقال بـ 60 في المائة
من متغير ألفا ، لذلك تحصل على
فكرة في اسكتلندا ، كانت هناك دراسة
تظهر أن الأشخاص الذين أصيبوا
بمتغير دلتا ، من المرجح أيضًا
أن يتم نقلهم إلى المستشفى.
يبدو أن هذا أكثر قابلية
للانتقال وأكثر خطورة
أيضًا ولهذا السبب هناك الكثير من
الاهتمام بهذا الأمر
إذا نظرت إلى فعالية
اللقاحات ألقي نظرة هناك
ترى أن ألفا أو دلتا تحصل
على الكثير من التأثير  الكثير من الحماية من
هذه اللقاحات ولهذا السبب
تظل الرسالة كما هي للذهاب إلى هناك والحصول على
التطعيم ،
فمن الجدير أيضًا الإشارة إلى أنه
يمكنك إبطاء انتشار t
الفيروس بشكل عام من خلال التطعيم من
خلال المناعة ،
ستكون أقل وأقل احتمالية
لتطوير طفرات في الواقع
تسبب مشاكل والتي
ستخلق المزيد من المتغيرات التي نشعر
بالقلق بشأنها باستمرار ،
بغض النظر عن الطريقة التي تقطعها بها ، بغض النظر عن الطريقة التي
تظل بها الرسالة كما هي  للذهاب
للتطعيم